>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR THE
VERY SPECIAL EDITION OF THE
DAN BONGINO NEWS EXPLOSION.
THE FAKE NEWS OF THE PAST BECOME
OUR FAVORITE FORMER
NEW YORK CITY POLICEMAN IS HERE
TO LISTEN.
IT IT HAS BEEN A REMARKABLY
BIZARRE 2028 DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGN.
DAN BONGINO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
DAN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> I HAD TO TAKE TO HEART THIS
ONE BECAUSE THERE WERE SO MANY
COMICAL DEMOCRATIC STORIES UP TO
THE CYCLE SO I DISTILLED THEM
DOWN TO FOUR.
HERE IS NUMBER FOUR.
THIS ONE'S GREAT.
REMEMBER OLD BARNEY CARTOON?
SHANG IS CARRYING?
NOT AT ALL CASES.
BETO DECIDED TO GO TO THE
DENTIST AND SHARE WITH THE
ENTIRE DENTAL VISIT.
THE CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN A CAVITY
EVER SINCE.
DOWN HILL, OVER AFTER THAT.
I DON'T BLAME THE DENTIST, I
BLAME BETO.
HE SOMETIMES SHARING ISN'T
CARING.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
AND NOT ALL OUR CYNICISM IS
REWARDED, INTERNS, WHICH IS A
GREAT MESSAGE.
IT'S GOOD.
>> REALLY, HE'S A NARCISSIST.
HE THINKS IT SO IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE HIS DENTAL
VISITS.
WE DON'T HEAR BUT THANKS FOR
TRYING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
STORY NUMBER THREE, THE 0% IS.
WHO HASN'T INVENTED THE CONCEPT
OF ZERO?
WAS AT THE BABYLONIANS OR THE
ABSENCE OF VALUE ALTOGETHER?
WELL, THAT IS SWELL WELL AND A
BALL ZEAL.
YOU ABSOLUTELY ATROCIOUS
POLITICIANS I HAVE A HARD TIME
DISCERNING WHICH ONE IS WORSE
BUT AT LEAST ONE OF THEM, AT
LEAST SQUALL WELL WAS SMART
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WHILE HE COULD
STILL PRESERVE THE WARM REMNANTS
OF HIS REPUTATION.
BILL de BLASIO, HE HAS NO SUCH
CONCERNS AT ALL.
THERE IS NO REPRESENTATION LEFT.
NUMBER TWO, KAMALA HARRIS CAN'T
SEEM TO TO DECIDE WHAT SHE WANTS
TO BE.
SHE FLIPS, SHE FLOPS, SHE FLIPS
AGAIN, SHE DID THE OLD 540.
180, 360, 540     540 PRINTED ON
HEALTH CARE, KENT DECIDED SHE
WANTS TO BE TOUGH ON CRIME,
LOOSE ON CRIME, SHE DOESN'T GET
IT.
THANK GOD TULSI GABBARD CALLED
HER OUT IN THE LAST DEBATE.
YOU SAW THAT.
I DIDN'T LOOK GREAT FOR HER.
AND NUMBER ONE, JOE BIDEN,
APOLOGIZING FOR BEING JOE BIDEN
BY JOE BIDEN CAN'T SEEM TO
FIGURE OUT WHO JOE BIDEN IS.
I HAD TO RIGHT GENERAL IS PURE
JOE BIDEN HAS TAKEN OPPOSING
POSITIONS ON HEALTH CARE,
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS THE WORK
TRUCK, THE HYDE AMENDMENT, ON
BUSING, APOLOGIZING FOR
JOE BIDEN IS OVER.